Now that's a contract.
But we still don't have a database.
Our database class
will extend an Android class.
SQLiteOpenHelper.
SQLiteOpenHelper contains cool stuff
to help us handle database versioning.
As we make changes
to our database in the future,
it will help us modify our tables.
For many apps, being able to upgrade
to a new version
without data loss is critical.
Let's create a WeatherDBHelper class
within the data package
and have it extend SQLiteOpenHelper.
We can add the required methods
by hitting Ctrl+I,
and we can override the constructor
by hitting Ctrl+O.
Now we can hard code
these variables to constructor.
Hard coding name to database name,
our factory to null,
and our version to database version.
Now, you'll note I have made
the database name public,
and that's because we're going to use it
in our tests in the future.
Now you see we've got it onCreate
and an onUpgrade method.
In the onCreate method,
we're going to start by creating a string
to build the weather entry table
using data defined
within the weather entry contract.
Now I'm just going to add this comment
so you know where to go back
and add the location entry stuff later.
Since weather entry
depends on location entry,
I would normally write
location entry first,
but weather entry is pretty complicated.
So I'd rather explain what we've done
and leave location entry up to you.
We're going to use raw SQL
for our create table query,
beginning with the table name
from our contract.
At this point, it's helpful to import
WeatherContract.locationentry
and weather entry.
It makes our query
so much easier to read.
We'll start with our ID field,
which we'll set as our primary key
in an auto increment field.
Note that integer is actually
a signed value
up to eight bytes long in SQLite.
Using the auto increment feature
doesn't do precisely what one might think.
Setting up the ID
is an integer primary key
actually makes the value unique
whenever you do an insert,
but it may not always increment.
It may reuse existing ID values
if the records have been deleted.
What auto-increment is really useful for,
is if you're synchronizing data
two ways with the server.
But, we'll take advantage of it here
because it makes data from our queries
sort a bit more naturally
because we insert them in the right order
coming from the server.
In general, we're using constraints
on fields. In this case, not null.
We do this because it allows
the database to do much
of our parameter validation for us.
The tricky part about doing it this way,
is that we don't get useful errors
when these constraints fail,
so it can be challenging to debug.
We're using a human readable string
for the date.
There's no strong reason for
or against this choice.
We wanted to normalize the date
to simplify our queries,
and human readability
simplifies debugging.
The date comes from open weather
in Unix time stamp format
with some time information
that we need to get rid of.
I'm not going to cover every field.
Real means floating point in SQL.
It would have been fine
to have used integer
with fixed point math as well
and some would argue
that this would be faster,
but real is more straight forward
since we're storing floating point values.
Now for the fun stuff,
we're going to set up a loc key.
It's a foreign key
to the location entry table
that you will be building.
This causes SQLite to enforce
the relationship between the tables.
We cannot insert a weather entry
when there is no corresponding
location entry.
And we cannot delete a location entry
if there are still weather entries
that depend on it.
Cool stuff, right?
One last constraint. Our date text
plus location must be unique.
On conflict, replace the data.
This allows us to insert new data
from the open weather EPI easily.
Preserving existing keys and updating
the value as the forecast changes.